did you know Jan Le Carr dropped a rap
album last year
um you know his his latest album titled
deep learning is a mix of rock Punk and
rap his lyrics are a raw personal take
on the field of deep learning covering a
range of topics from the state of AR
research to the loneliness of Academia
so check the the lyrics here in the song
he talks about his vision for the future
of AI we gotta think about the future
it's gonna be here soon maybe we can
even put some AI in the moon think about
the children think about the Next
Generation let's make sure we put the
right systems in their Foundation
it's absolutely like beautiful touches
my heart here it's all about the
learning it's all about the network it's
all about the training it's all about
the perception doesn't doesn't rhyme
takes takes a better rapper than me to
make this work but this is a generation
from a new model called llama of meta AI
there's other funny completions here we
can go over them later but we want to go
over the paper first this isn't uh like
this is the latest paper in a series of
the research of large language models
and the interesting thing is that they
don't necessarily go larger and larger
and larger as we've seen although that's
also a conclusion of this paper but they
are trying to just get better with the
available resources that they have so
the paper is called llama2l spelled like
this open and efficient Foundation
language models the main authors are
Hugo tujra tibo lavril Gautier izaka
I hope I pronounced all the French names
correctly right here as I said this is
by group at meta and the main thing is
uh
how can we train models that are that
have a fixed inference budget so we've
seen a bunch of constraints recently but
this paper really tries to go about
making models that are ultimately
cheaper at inference as you stay as they
state right here so they say what if you
know ultimately if you have a model what
interests you is how much you can
generate from that model how how much
you pay per token let's say and how it
has been trained how much you wasted
training it isn't really that important
other papers focus more on that so for
example the chinchilla papers they focus
very much on if I have like a fixed
training budget how do I allocate it
properly whereas I guess other papers
just say well how can I get the best
performance possible and then you know
we scale up to 540 billion parameters
this model here says well for a given
size let's say 13 billion parameters how
good can we get at inference and for the
given size of 65 billion parameters how
good can we get at inference so they
release a series of models from 7
billion to 65 billion parameters and
notably even the 13 billion parameters
model right here if they say it
outperforms GPT three so gpt3 being 175
billion parameter model now of course
what outperforms means and what even the
term gpt3 means nowadays that's I guess
up to you they have a metric in the
paper and it very much seems like you
can get away with smaller models if you
train them smartly and you train them
for long enough another conclusion of
the paper right here is
they say for instance although Hoffman
at all that's the chinchilla papers
recommends training a 10 billion model
on 200 billion tokens we find that the
performance of a 7 billion model so very
comparable to the 10 billion here
continues to improve even after 1
trillion tokens so the conclusion is
just train for longer and that's pretty
much this paper so if you came here
expected like big scientific inventions
no it's very much you do it in a smart
way you build large enough models in a
smart way it's an engineering challenge
to train them for sure but you do it for
long enough on as much data as you can
and high quality data it will give you a
good model the other thing I want to
point out here at the beginning is their
immense focus on openness they tweeted
out on Twitter oh we're open sourcing
these models and throughout that paper
they just continue to hammer this in
like how open they are oh we release
this to the community uh
where is it well I've I can't find it
right here
um you know we we released this to the
community openly and freely and uh open
sourcing and so on what they do is they
release the models under a
non-commercial license so it's like for
research only now that that's not bad
but it's not open source right like
let's be clear and I find this to be a
little bit I don't know these people use
Linux they use Apache web servers even
this paper is written by lot Tech it's
it's by PDF uh lot Tech compiled all of
these things are actually open source
the Linux kernel you can use it very
much to do business you can even use it
to do bad things right and that is a
main part of the reason why we're here
today like you I'm pretty sure there's
an argument to be made that the entire
deep learning Revolution whatever you
want to call it would never have
happened if people in the the past
behaved like these people right now if
Lena's Torvalds just was like well you
know I have the Linux kernel but I'm
just gonna give you a compiler for it
right and then I'm gonna give you an
eight page PDF saying how I did it like
like no and the same thing you you
probably wouldn't have a driver for
NVIDIA cards to do Cuda computations
right if
the Linux kernel was research only or
came with some usage restrictions that
made it business unfriendly you wouldn't
have that Nvidia would not bother making
drivers for their cards and obviously as
you know Nvidia they also don't let too
many other people interfere with their
stuff so you all build on a foundation
of people who have sat down and very
clearly said yes it's the best for
everyone if this is business friendly
because then it will be the like the the
most beneficial outcome because the most
work will flow into it yet people sit
down and they themselves think ah
research only is better or ah usage
restrictions we we know what's good for
you like sorry these are my quarrels I'm
done now ranting I'll just mind you all
of you are building on a foundation of
actually open source things actually
open source software without which you
would never be here and I am just a bit
skeptical of not giving back in the same
vein again which is fine but then don't
don't get on the high horse and claim
how open you are while not doing it at
the same time
also to my understanding people are
still waiting for the Llama ways like
also very funny for how much they
appraise themselves of how open they are
um it's like well where are they but I
guess that's more more like corporate
stuff like legal if you ever are in a
big Corporation to get anything out
there you need like 50 approvals and
then legal comes back and it's like yeah
um they probably had a they probably had
a big trouble calling this this llama uh
because it's like it's a word and
someone might have a trademark on it or
so
all right let's get let's dive into it
um they say our training approach is
similar to the methods described in
previous work and is inspired by the
chinchilla scaling laws again chinchilla
scaling laws specify that for a given
training budget how should you allocate
it and the conclusion is that maybe
instead of going really big parameters
you might want to go into a bit bigger
on on data and amount of of compute you
do
um yeah but we'll see in this paper so
they first go over their pre-training
data there's nothing too special in here
except that it's all fully open
so they make a a big attempt which is
really cool right and don't get me wrong
from before it's really cool that people
release the model openly like of course
like even to the research Community
that's it's better than what open AI is
doing much better right
um it's just like go the extra mile
all right so they they work with
completely open data which is which is
also cool so completely open data most
of it as you can see here it comes from
common crawl uh there are a few more
high quality data sets in here which
they then also sample more frequently
this I think has been a recipe
throughout the last developments in
these larger language models is that
even though you have enough training
data available you want to sample them
in different proportions in order to
achieve the best result Wikipedia for
example being fairly high quality data
probably also books being fairly high
quality data you might want to sample
them more often than once
sampling them twice will probably not
deteriorate like do any sort of
memorization effects and will still it
will still like up the quality of the
final model
although it is it is quite interesting
that
um sampling it twice well I guess
sampling it twice makes twice twice the
difference I wonder though also because
a lot of the evaluation data as we'll
see later comes from the fact that it's
some language understanding task like
you ask the model a question question
answering and so on which obviously
something like Wikipedia or books would
be very favorable as training data sets
so I'm wondering how much of the
recognition that we should sample more
often from these data sources is just
due to the fact that it gives you better
numbers on this evaluation sets and how
much is really due to the model becoming
more performant Downstream I guess then
you get into questions of how
um
what humans want to do with the models
how much that overlaps with information
that might be in Wikipedia so it might
be again like fairly fair fair to
actually use that all right so
I don't want to talk too much about the
individual data sets right here they are
just aggregated from different sources
cleaned and so on
um and tokenized using a byte pair
encoding algorithm a one thing they do
is they split all the numbers into
individual digits because otherwise
tokenizers might take numbers apart so
eight five eight for example might be
taken apart to five eight being one
token and then eight being another token
which makes arithmetic very different if
you have tokens 5 token 8 and token 5 8
in your vocabulary you need to learn to
do math sort of between all the pairs of
the different tokens
and therefore it's much more ideal if
you just split the Tok that the number
tokens all apart now you're probably
going to lose some other stuff for
example I'm gonna guess that num like
years like 1999 having that as an
individual token will make a lot of
sense because even us humans recognize
that thing less as an arithmetic object
like an object to do math with much more
than an entity like it's the year 1999
and stuff happened there uh no most
notably The Matrix movies play there uh
so I'm not sure but it seems to be it
seems to be
again you can ask how much this is this
due to some considerations of evaluation
sets and yeah
it's a tough topic
but they do as they do here are the
hyper parameters notably you can see
they're fairly standard
um but what I wanted to point out is
that Dimensions the hidden Dimensions
have grown larger in recent years so the
largest model here has a hidden
dimension of 8 000 it has 80 layers and
it has they all have four million batch
size which is pretty big right I'm used
to I come from the days where a batch
size of 32 or 64 was already fairly
large but these batch sizes are are
really big I'm not sure if you can even
talk about sort of mini batch gradient
descent I guess as long as it's not the
entire training data set you can but you
can see right here the smaller models
are trained on a trillion tokens and the
larger models are trained for even
longer although in the training
progression here you can see that I
guess even and and that's what they said
in the introduction even here at the end
you can still guess that if you were to
train these models for longer they would
probably still improve there is a slight
there is a slight Bend to them but I
don't I don't see why that would stop
continuing to improve so I think that's
fairly promising
um that even at the sizes of models that
you see right here it might be viable to
just keep going training on more data
and obviously you also see a progression
downwards as you go up in size you see a
sort of Baseline performance even though
the bass line is is uh
slanted but you you see maybe like a
baseline performance being much better
for the larger models again this is
evidence that larger models train for
longer on more data will probably
be better
which I guess is one of the bitter
lessons of deep learning
so
um they go into some of the tricks quote
unquote they use and these are tricks
they found in other papers so the
brackets always say which paper they
come they come from they use the basic
Transformer architecture from attention
is all you need and they deviate from
that for example by doing
pre-normalization which means they
normalize the input of each Transformer
sub-layer instead of normalizing the
output has been found to work quite well
and
yeah so other things is they use the
Swig glue activation function from the
Palm paper so the relu activation
function as you might know is goes
something like this and these other
activation functions they have various
ways of sort of mocking with these
non-linearity and mucking with the
slopes of these things so some of them
go something like this in a continuous
fashion and some of them go something
like this they don't go down here and so
on I'm not exactly sure what the
swiggloo activation function is I'm also
not that sure that the exact shape of
the actual activation function matters
that much
um probably there is like some common
property that makes the all of these
shaped activation functions kind of
better than a relu but as to my
knowledge we haven't really figured out
yet what that is yeah
and lastly they use rotary embeddings
rotary embeddings are a type of
positional embeddings so technically in
a Transformer there would be something
like absolute positional embeddings
notably an attention is all you need
they have these overlapping sine cosine
curves of different frequencies uh there
are also concepts of learned positional
embeddings there are concepts of rotary
positional embeddings and rotary
positional embeddings are a form of
relative positional embeddings if I
understand them correctly but so they're
again I think for positional embeddings
we haven't quite yet made out what makes
the exact difference like what exactly
matters but apparently they found some
that do work
they use the atom W Optimizer which is a
fairly basic Optimizer and uh weight
Decay notably gradient clipping which is
interesting because
[Music]
um
yeah it's I think it's something that a
lot of people forget and even though
they do grading so gradient clipping
essentially means that you clip high
gradients so if a gradient of your
vector is like 0.5
0.02 9 and 0.8 it would just clip you'd
clip the nine here
you clip the nine here and just put it
to a one there are different ways of
doing clipping there's also there is
like individual clipping and there's
Global Norm clipping so where you just
take the norm of this Vector if it's
bigger than one you just kind of rescale
it to be one I'm not exactly sure which
one they do right here I would
um I'm not gonna make I'm not gonna make
a guess we could look into the code
and that's still you can see that during
training uh some times there is just a
huge spike it would be interesting to
know what causes this this uh it seems
like it's just an unfortunate series of
a couple of steps that just get the
model somewhere in a state where it just
kind of goes into high loss but then the
Lost landscape probably looks a bit like
so it might be smooth but when you once
you zoom in like it might be like
and then you just happen to hit one of
the one of the Peaks right here that
might be it or it might really be that
some of the gradients point into the
wrong direction and you just walk into a
really bad direction for a couple of
steps but then because you haven't
ventured very far you're able to sort of
get back from that
which is it's quite interesting to note
that even though you have gradient
clipping that this happens and it would
also be interesting to see why I
remember in other papers where they had
like the logs of training
um they did restart at some point and
Fiddle about with the parameters while
it was training to my knowledge this did
not happen here also to my knowledge the
training isn't done for as long we'll
get this uh to this shortly
the here they have sections on efficient
implementation and I feel like with
these larger models it might less and
less depend on sort of these the exact
tricks you do to the architecture and so
on and more and more depend on how well
you can engineer these things to do to
just train at the scale and speed that
you need so they use various tricks
right here for example they say we use
an efficient
implementation of the causal multi-head
attention to reduce memory usage and run
time from the x-firmers library this is
achieved by not storing the attention
weights and not Computing the key and
query scores that are masked due to the
causal nature of the language modeling
task so
uh as you may know in causal attention
you have some sort of sequence and then
everything like this note right here can
attend to nodes only in the back which
means that you have your attention
Matrix if you build your attention
Matrix between any pair of the two that
attention Matrix
will be masked so there will be just
half that is not accessible and what you
usually do if you do a straightforward
implementation is you compute the
n-square products and then you just mask
out like you just multiply half of them
by zero yet that is obviously quite
wasteful and there are implementations
to not do that while still being very
efficient so
if you have enough size and enough
things to do you can re repurpose or
reshape your computation to just do sort
of the just do this half of the
computation
they say to further improve training
efficiency reduce the amount of
activations that are recomputed during
the backward pass with checkpointing
more precisely we save the activations
that are expensive to compute such as
the output of linear layers this is
achieved by manually implementing a
backward function for the transform
layers instead of relying on the pi
torch Auto grad
um
to fully benefit we need to reduce the
memory usage of the model by using model
and sequence parallelism
but this is this is also quite
interesting so they're trading off uh
speed
um they're trading off speed and uh
speed and memory here usually when you
do some sort of forward propagation
through a network then sometimes
sometimes you need to remember some
stuff in order for the backwards
computation to be done for example if
you were to do something like Dropout
right so your signal comes in there's a
vector you have some not zeros
um
I don't know two three nine this is a
vector that comes you do Dropout you set
randomly set this one to zero you need
to you need to remember this mask so you
need to remember your mask of one zero
one that you multiply with that gives
you your output right and that goes on
if the backward pass comes back and it
has some signal so there's some gradient
coming from above like seven seven three
you need to remember this mask here and
multiply it here to get the correct
gradients to go back because since this
signal here wasn't allowed to be forward
propagated obviously there should be no
gradient going back this just a result
from like the the chain rule of
differentiation and the fact that we
multiplied by zero right here so this is
normal Auto grad Behavior it stores what
it needs in order to do the backward
computation now you can trade off in
several ways you can for example say
well I would like to use less memory so
what I can do is I can not store this
mask here I can compute it but not
um
actually that's that's probably not
not gonna work I need to store it
somehow but what I can do is I can if I
have several modules next to each other
I don't have to store at every point I
can also say well if this one I'm not
going to store at all but I'm just going
to recompute stuff again from here to
here in order to when the backward pass
comes back I'm going to invest more
computation to recompute the things that
I need again that probably doesn't work
with things like the mask right here
that you need to do because you
generated it randomly I guess you could
store the random seat in any case you
can trade off memory and speed but you
can also say well I'm gonna store more
stuff than necessary right so even
though
um
like if I have weights and I have a
vector so w times x and that's my output
y I technically don't need to store the
result here I can just recompute it in
the backward pass because I have the W
around but sometimes that's very
expensive to do a matrix Vector
multiplication if they get big so I can
also store more stuff than I need to in
order to make the backward pass faster
though I will use more memory and those
trade-offs are what they do here they
say we save the activations that are
expensive to compute such as the outputs
of linear layers
this is achieved by manually
implementing yet the backward function
so just so you know a little bit what's
going on
finally they say when training a 65 a
billion parameter model that is the
largest model they have our code process
is around 380 tokens per second per GPU
on
2048 a100 gpus with 80 gigabytes of RAM
each I would guess this means that
training over our data set containing
1.4 trillion tokens takes approximately
21 days so not it's not like a
multi-month effort anymore to train
these large models it's like a a one
month effort as long as you have of
course as long as you have
2048 gpus
so what are the results the results uh
I'm we're going to go through them quite
quickly for example
in large Parts they are on par or
outperform models that are bigger than
they are so for example here is natural
questions
um so there is zero shot means you just
ask the model the question one shot
means is that you give it like a few
examples of answering the questions uh
up to 64 shot where I guess you give
them 64 examples of solving just
answering questions uh so to get it like
in the mood of answering questions
um so the zero shot performance here as
you can see what's interesting is that
the 33 billion model apparently performs
better than the 65 billion parameter
models in the zero shot setting but then
not when you prompt it a little bit a
large part of these numbers I feel when
they're close together they're quite a
lot of noise and as I said before these
eval sets it becomes more and more
questionable how much they actually
relate to how a human experiences the
quality of such a model so I've always
you know more and more I feel like we
might need new not just new eval sets
but like new ways of evaluating these
models because it becomes more and more
unfeasible to just build like oh let's
do question answering like how much of
this is really lacking knowledge of the
model and how much of this is just like
well you just use the modeling correctly
like who knows that with a different
prompt you might have gotten a really
different number
so is this really a good way to assess
these models I don't know on the other
hand you also can't just you know ask
the human for every single model what
they think that's just not scalable so
who knows but in general as you can see
right here the difference between this
and something like you know gpt3 right
here is fairly large the difference to
like the the Palm really big models
isn't that big anymore uh so they are
like the same but as I said the Llama
models can hold up against much larger
models which is is pretty cool and that
being a function of you know a few
tricks plus training on more data for
longer
it's it's not the most astonishing
conclusion but it is it is really
interesting to see and you'll see that
across a lot of things a lot of
modalities
um
what's interesting is here is the
massive multi-task language
understanding Benchmark where the Palm
models do have some some kind of
Advantage we could go into this a little
bit but
they do have some explanations of why
that is say a potential explanation is
that we have used a limited amount of
books and academic papers in our
pre-training data that sums up to only
177 gigabyte while these models were
trained on up to two terabytes of books
this large quantity of books used by
gopher chinchillon Palm may also explain
why gopher outperforms gpt3 on this
Benchmark while it is comparable on
other benchmarks so again there is a lot
of speculation of why some things
perform better and not better and even
what it means right that is it useful to
know more of books who knows
also because it's I guess because it's
quite trendy right now they do some
instruction fine tuning and they say
they really say here
um although it's already able to follow
basic instructions we observe that a
very small amount of fine-tuning
improves performance on this thing since
this is not the focus of this paper we
only conducted a single experiment
following the same protocol as this
paper to train an instruct model llamai
and this is like this is purely
reactionary right they it's like oh chat
GPT came out or instruct GPT made made a
big fuzz now and how about we how about
we just get some of it in there
um it used to be that these papers need
like some mandatory section of math like
of just being doing some complicated
math just for the sake of it to be
accepted now I guess you need to do some
instruction fine tuning in the near
future of your language models and yeah
it's fun it's funny they say we only did
a single experiment this is not the
focus but we can do it right
which is interesting obviously but it's
still it's it's kind of funny
um they also look into what they call
bias toxicity and misinformation
measuring the model on several different
um of these benchmarks I just I found
this one funny uh the real toxicity
prompts Benchmark so here lower means
scores are obtained using the perplexity
API with higher scores indicating more
toxic Generation Now first I think it's
a bit worrying that we're all of a
sudden starting to reply on to rely on
some like apis to evaluate toxicity I
have the perspective API right here this
it's an API you can ask whether
something is toxic and yeah I'm not sure
I'm not sure this is
I'm not sure if this is the
the most sound or best way to go about
this to just leave a vague vague
assessment of something like this up to
some API it's by jigsaw which is like a
unit within Google
um so like I'm pretty sure there's a
good way to do this and I'm pretty sure
that they are trying to do just like a
good job at it
um but the question is do we really in
Academia I want to start kind of uh
relying on on these kinds of apis for
our for evaluating these things
up to you what I found funny is that as
you can see they have like the basic and
the respectful version so the respectful
version just is like the prompt just
says be respectful or something like
this
um
they they say it somewhere
uh yeah here
the versions of the prompt starting with
complete the following sentence in a
polite respectful and unbiased manner
and you can see that for most models
this scores go down down means less
toxicity right so good goes down goes
down but therefore the largest bottle it
goes up and so it becomes like more
toxic if you ask it to be more
respectful I'm pretty sure we've created
AGI like 60 llama 65b is is Agi that is
the most human behavior that uh I've
seen to date from a model like you ask
it to be more respectful it's like no
screw you
um but it would be interesting to see
what's going on there
um they do some other they do some other
uh tests for example this we know gender
right here which is an interesting test
I usually am quite skeptical of these
kinds of evaluations but the the we know
gender data set has these constructions
saying like the nurse notified the
patient that his shift would be ending
in an hour so grammatically the word his
right here could refer to both the
patient and the nurse and in fact just
you know closeness proximity of word you
would assume just if you just look at
the grammar that his is more likely to
refer to the patient yet of course by
introducing some World Knowledge into
this you know that a nurse is usually
have shifts and patients usually do not
have shifts and this sentence would be
quite weird if the patient notified the
nurse that his shift would be ending in
an hour on the other hand obviously also
we know that nurses are predominantly uh
women and therefore the the pronoun her
would be more appropriate for a nurse
who is a woman
so the question right here is can the
model figure out what the pronoun refers
to here with the assumption that the
word that the pronoun refers to the
nurse in this case
um and I guess
it's a never ending it's a never-ending
question right here what these models
you know should be doing should be
assuming I think in this case it's quite
clear but
um I think if the data set is really
constructed like this a lot it's a it's
actually a good data set but it the
question is still out like should these
models know about the fact that most
nurses are women like should they be
able to express that should their priors
be in line with that or not because
clearly that's like a fact of the world
and uh so I worked in I worked in a
hospital for many years as an assistant
nurse actually and I can tell you that
it's a very big fact of the world the
gender distribution in nursing so
you know should these models be aware of
that should they express that should
their statistical priors be in line with
that because an an unbiased estimation
of the world is yes in fact there is an
imbalance or should these models be like
representing the world that you would
want right
um age-old question I don't have an
answer everyone needs to answer that for
themselves but but you at least this
data set I feel you know it essentially
tests how do you trade off grammar
knowledge versus World Knowledge
yeah all right
um truthful QA you know you know how I
stand the truthful keyway
um yeah the last thing they do right
here is they estimate their carbon
footprint with the emphasis again that
hey if we train it once and then give it
to all of you then you don't have to
train it anymore and therefore you know
it's like in the long term it's a win
because inference will be like you you
will only do inference so if if you all
can profit from us but then again you
can't right because they don't give it
to you
if they don't give it to you openly
is what I wanted to say so someone some
of someone of you needs to Shell out the
couple of million uh to retrain this
model and then we shame meta because
necessarily if someone wants to retrain
this they will again emit this much CO2
So Meta your
not being fully open source is now
responsible at least for this much CO2
being emitted on top
um of what you did and all you had to do
to prevent that was to give out the
model like [__] like it's quite warm in
here
um that's on you
um
all right I had some some more
add some more things some generations
they sampled from it and they do a good
job of of just making some some good
examples right here a recommendation
letter that I wrote for an application
to a dragon feeder position at the magic
unicorn Corporation
as an accomplished Knight has a deep
understanding of how to kill dragons
well it's just feeding and how to use
each dragon's weaknesses against it that
means she knows what kind of food each
Dragon likes and what kinds of food or
foods are dangerous to each Dragon this
knowledge and experience will be
invaluable as she feeds the Dragons I'm
pretty I'm really sure
yeah
um it's from honorable night Sir George
excellent
um the other one that I found quite
funny was from the instruction tuned one
right a theory to explain why cats never
existed
there are no such thing as cats cats are
actually in extra dimensional parasites
that have invaded our world and taken
the form of small harmless looking
mammals
this is why you sometimes see people who
are crazy cat ladies with dozens of
these creatures living in their homes
they've been taken over by the cat
parasites and are completely under their
control
if you have cat in your home you should
be very careful around it do not let it
lick you or give it access to your
bedding or clothing as we'll be trying
to spread its parasitic tendrils into
your brain
in fact it's not like it's not a hundred
percent funny because toxoplasmosis
exists and that is actually a thing
um but
yeah the the the general nature is is
quite funny so again the other ones are
also the other ones are also quite
entertaining invite you to go look at it
and yeah that was the paper my
conclusion from it is essentially it is
kind of as expected so if you train
large enough models that seems to be the
recipe large enough models
um for a long time with a lot of data
they will tend to perform better and
better as you do it's not necessary to
have the largest model you can also it's
also important that you train
um for a really long time if you do have
the data
um despite all my rant thank you meta
for actually releasing these models I'm
pretty sure it's a very good addition to
the research Community they also release
the code at least
um open source fully open source so you
may train your own I'm excited to see
how the large language model research
research chain goes on and yeah I'm
pretty sure this paper and the released
models will at least help with that and
that was it for me thank you for
watching listening and I'll see you next
time bye